okay so here's here's the point I want  to make there's the point that's so I  think so indispensable is that like when  Paul Ryan or one of these trickle-down  clowns says when when when when wages go  up employment goes down that sounds like  a description of reality that sounds  like legit economics it is not it is an  intimidation tactic masquerading as an  economic theory it's a way it's a way  for powerful people it is a way for  powerful people to bully people without  power it look it's the oldest trick in  the business man's job suppression  handbook you asked for a ways you asked  for raise I threatened to fire you and  people have to begin to hear this for  what it is it is not a description of  reality it is it is them saying in other  words we matter you don't